sapete tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
fine io sono fan i geologi siamo tornati
su quel gioco l'acqua il gioco dove la
gente muore e quello là mancano ancora
un po di livelli classici da fare no è
che sono i rock swing cioè tra in dieci
minuti
uno di questi che un livello classico e
il bold trovo appunto e manca la
versione in dieci minuti prete volo via
parti dieci minuti all'ora primo
purtroppo vediamo quanti di scappare che
è una mostra o mio dio cosa diavolo è
aiuto non capisco 4 ma tu sei amatrice
un gioco il gioco del tris ma veramente
ma bellissimo questo livello è un
controllo del tris fantastico qui di
primo livello penso sia il più lento
effettivamente perché difficilissimo
spero di vincere tra l'altro uno ok
devo andare sul 9 sono questo 9 9 9 9 99
non è perfetto mese perfetto effetto
meraviglioso perché gli ho bloccato il
risultato attenzione se va sul 6 ha
vinto lui pensa te ma non su sei ho
vinto io sono scemo devi andare sul 6 0
su 6 risupera l'auto risupera lotto di
sopra latte riso prodotto
si no muori maledizione va beh speriamo
che non vada su sei nata su 7 quindi ho
vinto io
giuseppe io adesso il prossimo bilancio
faccio se io ho vinto ma iniziano perso
solo un minuto per fare questo certo
livello e lentissimo porco demonio non
vale dai dai dai dai dai veloci veloce
veloce 6 e ho vinto tra i deve fare
tutto il giro sono stupido posto
lanciarlo molto più lento dai
maledizione 8 minuti e 40 dai dai dai
dai dai dai dai veloce ok
prima abbiamo vinto il secondo cioè
penso che quelli questi sono molto più
votati della storia quindi credo che i
primi siano veramente lenti da fare è
normale perché se sono i più votati
nella sola vuol dire che hanno qualche
particolarità capito se hanno qualche
particolarità vuol dire che sono più
lenti da fare per essere i ball trovo
quindi tipo questo fa che devo fare i
10.000 punti
però attenzione li ho fatti ma devo
farne 100.000 e qui
no fermi devo fare 100 mila può è
impossibile non li posso fare scelto
mila punti
devo fare a locke e poi devo andare sul
finale subito provaci mamma mia
dai ma porca vacca come faccio parte
perfetto 22 22 28 minuti rimanenti by
uno al minuto che sto facendo è
difficilissimo perché quelli più votati
sono lentissimi l'affare win
poi ci credo è difficilissimo perché qui
dai lorello presa l'hanno presà dove la
vittoria dove la vittoria dove è la
vittoria che porta la chioma che schiava
di roma che dio che no dove sto facendo
ma a me è un rap singh più jack folla e
vabbè allora io ho già scritto sei già
scritto ma l'inizio è che non so leggere
ok quindi non fare tutti e due non ho
ancora vinto ma vera che non c'è però
mai lo dico no non ce la farò mai
non ce la farò mai io faccio pagare i
jackson non vale però è un volto non è
un gesto loeb ed ai ok ho fatto anche il
terzo ko ko vittoria domande sulla
vittoria veloce ma togli le mani ct
pachino disco partire un livello perché
mi si cassano le mani bellissimo proprio
lui proprio lui boltro bingo
no dai vi prego non fare o non ho mai
fatto nella mia vita di fv su boltro
dovessero ste cagate neofascisti non so
come si gioca vivo quindi gioco a caso
ho sempre fatto rob ha sempre fatto
sempre fatto roba dove vi sono centrare
la vittoria adesso mi fanno fare ste
robe con i numerini che va dai è
veramente non so come si giochi a via
pingo spero che va dalla vittoria e
basta come ci giocano i vecchi a vigo e
vecchi vecchi americani giocano
avvengono sono capace non sono capace
giocare a bingo non è che devo beccare
free che c'è nel senso dove tira libro
con la palla sul free
no ho beccato quindi maledizione non
solo i dati non ho idea raga non ne ho
la minima idea vi giuro non ne ho la
minima idea
penso che io debba mettere tutte le
palle impilate in pilates che devo fare
almeno cinque penso che io debba fare
almeno cinque numeri di fila c'è devo
metterli in fila cosa veramente
difficile a quanto pare visto che non è
successo neanche mezza volta però non ne
ho idea ce la sto lanciando palle a caso
quindi 14 19 14 e 19 14 e 19 quello e 15
non è 14 il 18 solo il 18 solo il 18
solo il 18 il 19 anche 19
il 19 anche lo aveva bene codici che non
c'era una sega parco demonio 11 mandano
sull'undici che costa con l 11 0 ma fa
niente
lumino
e tanto non sapere che si gioca lo ha
dato per scontato per scontato proprio
ma perché mi fanno fare tutti io non ho
mai giocato un po altro dove ci sono ste
cose ci sono la vittoria non ho mai
giocato un po troppo ste cagate mai
tutte adesso devo fare la va beh vuol
dire che battere record sarà più
difficile ragazzi che vedo io è questo
no ho vinto fantastico grazie bene cioè
io sto giocando in questi giochi questi
si giocano si ma stai calmo stai calmo
questi poi trovano giocati quelli là
dove c'è la vittoria alla fine ed
eviterà la palla non questi altri non
vale maledizione poi non vedi questi
vanno giocati sono più veloci porco
demonio sono bravino quelli che fai
l'attrice bingo è il mercante in fiera
il poker e dai e su lupus in tabula luke
c'è pure ma dai dov'è la vittoria
victory bay basketball dunk quindi se io
tiro quella la ributta fare basket for
the basketball da anche nel senso ha la
scritta forse dove centra il canestro
d'età
stephen curry come lui tensione contro 2
sarà anche cosa sia però va be nice
wow qua devo fare i punteggi alti un
altro contro tutto strano fatto da pic
torino 99 attenzione per la testa di ho
vinto vinto perché questo fatto col
punteggio massimo non c'e la vittoria
che non l'ha messa ma ho vinto perché
punteggio massimo ok neon win laica boss
non lo prenderò mai nuclear pup va bene
quanto ma anche al 2000 è quella che sta
accelerando ai ragazzi di the core non
l'ho detto ma basta pingo basta io non
ho mai giocato in 172 episodi di happy
mi sono mai giocato contro diverso da
quelli col win è libero tutti adesso ho
il bingo poi che faccio pagare a bingo
day peccare lati
l'artista la mia vittoria da meno a
vittoria si meraviglia che significa che
c'è adesso l'ho vinto subito prima non
riuscivo a vincerlo mai ma subito guarda
quanto ci metto beccare il win
hai visto che faceva tutto il figo che
riusciva beccarlo invece no attenzione
attenzione attenzione dai due minuti dai
l'ho preso sono veramente un fenomeno
mamma mia tutta la piccola mia porta non
vedo la vittoria ma la vinco lo stesso
eccola e difficili dove sto andando dove
vado
va benissimo anche così ragazzi ma va
benissimo ma chi lo disdegna questo
traguardo va benissimo dove la vittoria
qua no era arrivato però di fatto era di
nera libro giuro
certamente ma la spinta se non fosse
stato per con la spinta avrei vinto
spingimi le palle
né c'è nel senso riva ben capito ok ok
bella lì proprio lui un minuto 25
ragazzi poi li contiamo perché non so
quanto sto facendo guarda che ragazzi
sto facendo un punteggio incredibile per
le per le partite che ho trovato è
fidatevi per le partite che ho prodotto
sto facendo punteggi incredibile perché
non erano così facili che ho fatto ho
fatto bingo potuto giocare a bingo cioè
una roba allucinante mi sono veramente
orgoglioso
sto facendo però non puoi mettermi in
corso davanti a vittoria unico mai se no
sono ancora vivo scherzoso vai con la
testa
sapete vero che se mi parte la testa per
caso e va sulla vittoria vinco però
impossibile
ho vinto due volte sono i due subito due
palle attenzione 45 secondi ragalato
swim subito perfetto maledizione alla
vita 37 calhoun ko perfetto eccolo dai
dai dai veloce però c'è con la vita
stessa di luke madonna se avessi
sbloccato la porta così sarebbe stato
incredibile sbloccare la porta e
prendere su win non ce la farò mai
non ce la farò mai perché per beccare
quello no ma è impossibile 14 secondi ma
che ce la posso fare
no non ci credo ho fatto esattamente il
verso di noi sa che quando muore ma
niente dai film del tempo va bene va
bene
sono comunque soddisfatto perché ho
fatto partito neo 9 10 11 12 34 15
boltro in dieci minuti e tra l'altro 123
questo non lo ricordo 4 e 5 cinque di
questi hanno il possibile già il tris il
bingo e tu sorelle c'era tutto quindi
legati era veramente novati 15 ma il
signor veramente un signor risultato per
quello che ci aveva quindi se fate tutti
questi di fila dovete fare software by
rating mondiale e trovati livelli più
votati della storia di happy meals di
boltro fate i primi 15 v sfida veramente
quale 15 un risultato veramente sono
orgoglioso di me stesso io chiamo mia
mamma però vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
schierati a canale 15 pole trovi dieci
minuti niente vale sia seta campanellina
prima le ragionati suoi video speriamo
di fare ancora meglio del prossimo che
non sarà ovviamente dimostrò perché
basta fare un altro eroe come sempre in
attesa di apv 2
ci vediamo al prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]